sometimes there's a misconception that
google cloud only runs tensorflow
well there are many deep learning
libraries out there and GCP runs much
more than just tensorflow how do we get
other machine learning library is
running on GCP stay tuned to find out
welcome to AI adventures where we
explore the art science and tools of
machine learning my name is yu phango
and on this episode we're going to see
how to run pi torch on google cloud
there's a lot of options so let's dive
right in if you want to get your hands
on pi torch and have no installation or
setup then there's well no easier way to
do so then using something like collab
ortega kernels you can just sign in with
your google account and you're ready to
use pi torch just import and go collab
has a neat github integration
additionally that allows you to pull in
any public ipython notebook file on
github directly into collab so if you're
working through an examples repo and you
want to try modifying and running the
code for yourself it's super easy you
can just go to file open notebook select
the github tab and paste in the URL of
the repository or that user's name you
can also link directly to a github
notebook in collab by copying the URL
that comes after github.com and pasting
it directly after collab dot research
that google.com slash github which we
are showing here now on the cago side of
things there's a vast library of kernels
available from the community across many
datasets often with excellent discussion
and annotations so you don't have to
start from scratch and again you don't
have to worry about installing anything
or doing configuration just sign in and
you're ready to edit your code another
option for the PI torch developers out
there are the deep learning virtual
machines which we've covered a couple
different ways on this show you can
select an image that is pre baked with
PI torch alongside any Nvidia drivers
you may need for GPUs that you might
choose to
attach this option is great if you
really want to crank up that compute
power and have full control over your
environment including being able to save
your work directly to your virtual
machine as opposed to Google Drive on
colab or on Chicago kernels finally I
want to point out that Google is working
with the PI torch team to enable tensor
board support to visualize training
progress as well as TPU support so
considering that you can run collab with
TP use for free that's going to be an
awesome combo so if you're overflowing
with ideas about how you'd like to use
cloud GPUs with PI torch email the team
at PI torch - TPU at Google Groups comm
- tell them what types of PI torch
workloads you would most be interested
in accelerating there are options to
suit all kinds of pi torch use cases on
GCP whether you are looking to just get
started or if you're looking to spin up
a big training job there's a solid PI
torch friendly way to get it done on
Google Cloud thanks for watching this
episode of cloud AI adventures and if
you enjoyed it be sure to hit that like
button and subscribe to get all the
latest episodes right when they come out
for now jump over to your favorite
environment to run PI torch on GCP today
[Music]
[Music]